hello everyone welcome to another
episode of history of science and
technology q a
it's my chance to
tell you guys things that i might know
from personal experience about history
of science and technology or things that
i've researched about that
um and i'm happy to talk about both
specific questions and general topics
um
and let's see we have uh all sorts of
questions saved up here
um
that's one question from aaron
in 800 years what will people call the
methodology of a new kind of science
it's an amusing question
you know
so
my big book a new kind of science which
is about to be 20 years old sort of the
big point
is the study of simple programs and what
they do
as distinct from
using things like mathematical equations
as the raw material for making models of
things like the natural world
and
well you know let's talk about the
history
of uh
the naming of
things
uh that describe the natural world so
back in in antiquity
sort of talking about nature
was i guess a branch of philosophy
although i don't think philosophy had
really been given that name at that
point
um you know aristotle for example had a
book called the physics
and i think
in those days
uh you know if you look at for example
galen's work
um in what first century or so i think
uh
you know he has books about
medicine
physiology
that are also books about what we would
now call physics
the nature of the natural world so to
speak and i think that there was a
strange sort of intertwining
of sort of uh the natural world of of
how us humans work with the natural
world of how you know rocks and and so
on you know that uh work
so
i think uh sort of
back in the in the uh in antiquity kind
of no great distinction made between
sort of the figuring out of how things
work so so it's worth understanding that
in those days
kind of the notion of science wasn't
really quite the same as the notion of
science today i mean there's the
question of how do you figure out how
things work
what kinds of things
things like
arguments that people make
about
that turn into things like logic and in
the hands of aristotle and so on or
how things work as in you know how a
plant grows
or how life is formed those kinds of
things now you know for aristotle for
example who was a great cataloguer of
things
a cataloguer of you know
types of mollusks and a cataloguer of
types of arguments and logic and a
catalogue of causes of things and so on
uh as as that sort of great catalogue
he would make arguments about how things
work
that were what we would now consider
philosophical arguments and sometimes he
would just make statements about this is
how
this kind of organism grows sometimes
those were right sometimes those were
wrong but the notion that one would just
use one's everyday experience and one's
powers of reasoning to work out how the
world works that was kind of what was
assumed to be the way things were set up
and
for i would say a very long time
that was kind of the the the you know
aristotle's work was viewed as sort of
the the canon of you know beyond
religious texts that was kind of viewed
as the as the canon of knowledge that
was being passed down
and i think
that the idea that the way the world
works is something that you can either
make just general observations on or you
can reason about was kind of what was
assumed it wasn't assumed that there was
a big tower it was kind of like either
you dissect the frog and it has this
thing in it
or you reason about
uh how you know the frog must jump this
or that way it wasn't expected that
there was a large kind of formal tower
that will be built where for example one
would do things like one might do with
modern mathematics or modern computation
where you would start from some set of
rules let's say and you build this big
tower of consequences on top of that it
was much more kind of uh sort of direct
and i think that um
and similarly even with logic which we
might now think had many steps of
deduction and so on the logic of
aristotle and even through the middle
ages was syllogistic logic which was
mostly you memorize certain patterns of
arguments and i think two famous ones
had the acronyms barbara and celerent
and they were just things like i don't
really remember
maybe i've never known uh kind of that
things like you know you can say p and
you can say q and you can say not p
you know if p implies q then not p
you know what does that imply that's a
form of argument that you can give
and people would just sort of memorize
structurally those forms of arguments it
wasn't what we would now expect to be
the case
where it's kind of you know given the
rules of logic you can build this giant
tower of uh of consequences on top of
that that that notion i think didn't
really exist in those days now there was
a notion of mathematics from uh
babylonian times euclid things like that
had a notion of mathematics that was a
place where that kind of deduction
really was done but i don't think that
was really connected uh so much into
into science
now subsequently many you know couple of
thousand years later
when well okay i should say that that
uh people like ptolemy certainly use
geometrical arguments to talk about
astronomical phenomena when eclipses
would occur things like this that was in
first century a.d or so um the uh
then but
this
this notion i suppose that that in
science
you can
have well it's sort of an interesting
question did
ptolemy in his presentation was very
euclidian
very much you know there is this
statement about uh you know the earth is
in this position the moon is in this
position therefore there will be this
number of eclipses per year when these
things are rotating around i i think
that in many ways
that was viewed as being sort of a
self-evident truth given that the earth
was in this position it was going around
the sun the question of why was it going
around at that rate you know why would
the moon
why was the moon orbiting in this way or
the moon slowing down or or even things
like tides were not something that was
understood at the time because in a
sense
what i i would say perhaps ptolemy was
talking about is just
things are this way
just like a euclid might say one has a
right triangle of this form therefore
what what are the consequences of that
ptolemy was like saying the earth is
going at the speed the moon is going at
the speed what are the consequences of
that as well might deduce them like
euclid would have deduced things about
pure geometry the notion that there
would be some kind of
uh sort of explanatory story of like why
are there tides i don't think was was
was uh was part of that um uh that that
thought
so i think
then
kind of physics
well there wasn't really a term physics
except this rather confused thing uh as
i say aristotle had a thing called
physics um but uh
really the the general category was
natural philosophy um the kind of the
the philosophy the reasoning about how
nature worked
and and reasoning was pretty much what
it was
and the idea that one could like do
systematic experiments
do elaborate formal deductions of how
things worked in the world
wasn't really a notion i mean the the
notion of of um
uh of sort of systematic experiment
that's uh
often attributed to francis bacon
um around
1600 late 1500s
um i think curiously francis bacon i i
think was
was more a courtier and politician
than he was necessarily a scientist
and in a rather ironic turn given what's
happened 500 years later
the
part of his sort of statements about you
know
we have this notion of science we have
things which can be deduced to be true
by doing science experiments and they
are
they are definitively true because we
prove them with science by doing these
experiments part of his rhetoric at
least around that idea
was to use it in a sense for political
purposes to say we discovered this from
science so you can't argue about it it's
not something where you know in in past
times people would have said you know
it's it's in our it's in the bible it's
in some religious text
therefore it is true we can't argue
about it and that was you know when
you're setting up a country or something
and you can say you know we're operating
under god in this you know with these
god-given laws so to speak
then you you kind of you know one can
one can feel like one's doing something
where there's no argument about that
that's just the way things are just like
when one might say once dealing with
euclid or or elementary arithmetic you
know one plus one equals two is just the
way things are there's nothing really
you can argue about that and i think
what francis bacon was was going for was
sort of another track where it's just
this is just how the world works we can
do empirical science we can discover
this is how the world works and then
there's nothing to argue about
and he saw that as being something
significant
for for sort of uh having a sense of
authority in uh in doing things like
running countries and so on and it's
sort of ironic that 500 years later you
know we're somewhat subject to the same
kinds of uses of science um in you know
in these pandemic times so to speak uh
this kind of it's science so you have to
believe it kind of thing uh of course
that's not really science is a
complicated thing and some kinds of
science uh some kinds of you know one
plus one equals two kinds of things yes
it has to be that way but there is a lot
more complexity in kind of what's really
true in science and how you know what's
true than perhaps people uh you know the
francis bacon model is just tell them
it's science and they'll believe it type
thing um but that's really not uh
not not the right story now i think
then this kind of notion of you can do
experiments you can do systematic
experiments the thing that is is not at
all obvious
and uh it's sort of a a fact about the
world that one has to kind of uh in a
sense uh
perhaps well deduce know it's true etc
is the idea that you can do
a repeatable independent experiment
that is that you can do an experiment on
one part of the world
that
is independent of the rest of the world
so for example you you do the experiment
in paris you do the experiment in london
it's if you control the environment of
the experiment it doesn't matter whether
it's in paris or london you'll still get
the same result it is not self-evident
that
any independent experiments can be done
in the world it's not in in some areas
of social science that's even less clear
that you can do an independent
experiment that you can do something
where the environment is controlled to
the point where you do the experiment
once you do it again you define the sort
of the parameters of the experiment and
you can repeatably do the experiment
that's kind of a a critical assumption
of empirical science
and you know there are senses even in
physics in which that's just not true
it's kind of like the heraclitus line of
you know you never step in the same
river twice type thing things have
always changed i mean that's that's part
of uh um well in the end in sort of our
models of physics and we can get into
all kinds of quantum mechanics and no
cloning theorems and so on and quantum
mechanics of of being very much related
to this idea that there is a history to
the world and if you do something you do
something at one time in the history of
the world it will inevitably be
different from doing it at another time
in the history of the world even this
sort of very microscopic level of
physics
but but i think in kind of the
progression of kind of what one meant by
natural science or natural philosophy
rather um that was a thing that you know
so the experiment idea came in and then
kind of the big thing mid 1600s to 1687
and so on this idea of mathematics as
being something could directly inform
natural philosophy and that led to the
you know the name of isis newton's book
in 1687 you know principia mathematica
principalis
i can't do the latin but the english
translation is
mathematical principles principle
mathematica
of natural philosophy
so the the the notion that that uh
newton had was you can take these ideas
from mathematics essentially from euclid
the the idea of sort of a deductive
system from euclid and you can apply it
to natural philosophy
and that was kind of the big the big new
idea i mean galileo had had had uh sort
of pieces of that idea um and so on but
that was the big thing was that you can
take uh you you can actually build up a
deductive system in natural philosophy
you can say you know there is an inverse
square law of gravity and then deduce to
do seduce you know the comets have to
move in this way the structure of the
solar system is this and so on and that
you know that became the story of of
physics
and um uh was was kind of that was that
was the direction from then on out now
then
classical physics developed from kind of
newtonian paradigm mathematical
equations newton worked out the
equations of mechanics of classical
mechanics
um you know subsequently equations of
elasticity theory deformations of solids
uh fluid flow equations then late uh mid
to late 1800's the equations of
electromagnetism maxwell's equations and
so on all very much in the same
mathematical framework of the financial
equations that newton had basically
introduced although originally newton's
notation
and presentation was much more euclid
style much more proposition
you know essentially axiom you know
newton's laws for newton were like
axioms the fact that you know force
equals mass times acceleration was kind
of like
for i think for newton like the idea you
know in euclid two parallel lines will
never cross
there was kind of i think
not
you know that this this notion that you
could have mathematical principles of
natural philosophy was something that
was
uh
euclid what was the status of what
euclid was doing what was euclid doing
what was he thinking of when he said two
parallel lines could never cross
was that supposed to be a statement
about nature or was that supposed to be
a statement of self-evident truth
about a
construction that euclid was coming up
with i think for euclid it was
effectively a statement of self-evident
truth
because euclid didn't realize that you
know two thousand years later people
would start talking about curved space
where two parallel lines you can cross
um
and and can intrinsically do so
so i think for for for euclid it was
kind of like take our everyday
experience
that becomes self-evident to us
and then put it in axiomatic form and
then make deductions from it by the way
the work i've been doing recently on
metamathematics
kind of uh kind of informs that a little
bit differently but maybe i shouldn't
get off into that into that direction
right now but but the um uh but then for
for newton the question was was f equals
ma sort of an axiomatic fact
that was in the same status as euclid's
axioms or was it something more in the
baconian tradition of we observed this
to be the case
i kind of think newton was going more
for the euclid idea and in a sense you
know force equals mass times
acceleration is at some level a
definition of force that's newton's
second law but newton's first law you
know an object stays in a in in uniform
uh motion in a straight line if not
acted on by a force
i don't know what that is that's a
that's a funny statement because that
statement again
is a statement that is actually very
similar to
euclid's parallel lines don't cross
it in some sense is assuming flat space
and things like this
um and uh uh anyway i i think you know
the sort of the philosophy the true
philosophy of what was really being
meant by these things i i think was was
only implicit at the time
but but so then
getting to the late 1800s where we've
got the whole stack of capabilities of
classical physics based on differential
equations and then comes quotes modern
physics
and you know people are still they
they'll have courses but you know
everybody has courses on modern physics
what is modern physics modern physics is
a century old modern physics
is the study of things like relativity
quantum mechanics atomic physics things
like this
um that is
it is modern in the sense that it was
not classical in the sense that it does
not go back to newton um you know you
could go back even further to aristotle
that wouldn't be the kind of thing that
is taught in physics today
i mean there are there are phenomena
that um uh
you know if you look at one of the
things that's been sort of interesting
in the history of physics
is that uh there's sort of been these
these levels of you know there's sort of
aristotelian physics
in which for example in particular the
most one of the significant things about
motion in aristotelia and physics is
uh you know in order to get something to
move you have to keep pushing it
whereas in newtonian physics newton's
first law critically says
if there isn't a force acting on
something it'll just keep going
if it's in you know if it's not in a
gravitational field if it's out in a
vacuum and so on it just keeps going of
course in aristotle's time
there weren't you know
i don't know what you know air hockey
tables or something you know there
weren't things where you could where you
could reasonably have very low friction
and where things would just keep going
in a straight line in aristotle's time
most things that moved you had to keep
pushing them so it wasn't unreasonable
for aristotle to to make the claim that
motion is something that you have to
keep pushing to make it happen so to
speak
so but um
i think then the um uh the sort of the
the defining characteristic of of
classical physics
um
well it's i mean it's sort of physics
where
i don't know actually what what what is
the right i mean
historically there's a well-defined kind
of notion of the distinction between
classical physics and modern physics is
kind of pre-1900 physics and post-1900
physics
one can point to it's kind of like when
did newton's laws of motion no longer
really apply either because of
relativity or because of quantum
mechanics
but so that's been the the kind of the
idea of um you know physics there um and
uh you know i i i am somewhat amused by
the question of what in our modern you
know i was going to say modern theory of
physics but that would be a
even more confusing thing
in the fundamental theory of physics
that we've developed in the last couple
of years which is kind of another step
beyond what was done a hundred years ago
in the development of relativity and
quantum accounts kind of a lower level
understanding of what's going on and
more global understanding what's going
on it's paradigmatically rather
different from what's been done before
and you know the question is how long
will it be before modern physics
is is called let's say 20th century
physics or something um to uh to
distinguish it from what we now have
which i guess is 21st century physics um
and uh
i think we're finally at the end so to
speak in the sense that people have
wondered for a long time you know is
there a bottom to physics you know as
you go down and down and down do you end
somewhere or does it is it kind of this
sort of infinite regress of will always
be a better theory and that was that's
again been something when people have
looked at theories in science
one of the things that's typically
observed is we have a model it works up
to this level but there'll always be a
better model i think in our fundamental
theory of physics now we reach the end
we have you know we have something which
is vastly bigger and you know our
perception of it our experience of the
universe is a tiny slice of everything
that's there but i think we kind of know
famous last words but i think we know
what's there i mean i think this thing
we call rouliad is kind of the the
ultimate story of what's there
underneath physics and mathematics as it
turns out so it's sort of an interesting
historical moment because you know
there's been this progression
only
i would say this idea that um there
isn't
there isn't an end to physics it's
really probably two three hundred years
old not more than that people before
that just sort of said well we'll get to
the end you know people in antiquity
were like it's all made of atoms and
that's kind of the end um and even in
times of you know descartes for example
was talking about you know maybe in a
hundred years we'll know
it all so to speak it's only a more
recent thing as sort of we went from
sort of classical physics and then we
find out
quotes modern what are they claiming now
should be renamed 20th century physics
um that's actually uh yeah people should
rename those classes 20th century
physics not modern physics
um in any case but the question
so now
i think the original question that was
asked was what will the thing that i
call the new kind of science
um back in 20 years ago get called a
long time in the future
you know i'm sort of amused to note that
um
some people were like i think i think
nowadays people would mostly say you say
what should one have called that book
the name a new kind of science is the
right name for it which is what i
thought at the time because as people
kind of try and describe it it's like
well it is kind of a new kind of science
relative to what had come before but i i
felt very deflationary in some ways
because galileo had a book called two
new sciences i'm not actually sure what
they were anymore but um uh you know a
new kind of science is is uh is kind of
only one of it so to speak relative to
galileo's two of it
um but any case and and i didn't uh i
didn't do what galileo did although it's
a very interesting sort of device i mean
galileo wrote i think that book
in um uh as a like a play as kind of a
discussion between multiple uh
characters i think three characters
there um and i have to say that that the
notion of kind of explaining things in
that sort of q a format i think is
actually pretty pretty powerful and
maybe i should try more of it um but uh
in galileo's time i mean i i'm i'm sort
of uh in a sense the the pure sort of
shakespearean aspect of it as a play i
don't know whether anybody's performed
the two new sciences thing as a kind of
as an actual discussion between people
it certainly could have been done that
way i'm not sure it was great literature
in that regard but it was a useful
device
um i think galileo famously had one of
his characters i think called simplicius
um who was a kind of a simpleton who was
sort of a proxy people claimed was a
proxy for the position being taken by
the catholic church at that time um i'm
not sure i think galileo was a quite um
a small
uh
red-haired energetic aggressive fellow
um and uh who was who was i think um
quite
uh quite um sort of uh brash in his
interactions with people and i think um
uh you know that that sort of carried
over to his his interaction with the um
um with
the the sometimes rather
rather backward but sometimes not so
backward uh theologians of the time
but you know i will say that in terms of
of
what i call new kind of science this
exploration of the computational
universe of possible programs
that is sort of a different paradigm
from this mathematical paradigm that was
kind of the newtonian idea from 1687 and
so on that kind of led to the
mathematical sciences and sort of the
mathematicization
of of physics for instance
uh the the the kind of what we're doing
in modern times one could think of as
the the computationalization
of things like physics
but i think the the the pure basic
science of what do simple programs do
that's a different kind of science
that's why i call the book a new kind of
science because that's sort of its
foundation is what do simple programs do
what is that it's not mathematics
mathematics is about uh has has ended up
being about specific kinds of structures
that are sort of accessible to humans in
various ways arithmetic geometry things
like that this idea of you just write a
program it's certainly not computer
science computer science is a story of
writing programs that are useful for
particular purposes we write a program
for a purpose
it's actually not really a science in
that sense it's more a thing that is
where one is using computers to achieve
engineering technological purposes
the the kind of this this science of
kind of what is out there in the
computational universe of possible uh
programs that's what might have been
called computational science if that
name hadn't been taken for other
purposes so quite recently i kind of
came up with the name ruleology to
describe this the science of exploring
the consequences of simple rules so i
would say that the um
you know i'm going to wait i i don't
know how long it'll be before they're
the first professors of ruleology but i
think it will happen and that field of
exploring simple programs and what they
do as a matter of abstract science it's
an extremely fertile field and there's
just it's just so much to do and it has
the feature that when you deliver things
you get to apply them it's a very
upstream kind of science it's it's a
kind of science where when you discover
something it has many downstream
consequences for many different purposes
a little bit like some areas of
mathematics where you discover something
about some kind of differential equation
and by golly that the application of
that uh you know applies to all these
different areas
so it's something where once you
discover something about this pure basic
science of ruleology you can then flow
that down into it into many applications
and so i think that's a a very uh it's
sort of a an area that kind of like pure
mathematics is something that sort of
has this consequence that it exports to
all these different application areas
it's been a thing that hasn't really
been had a a well-integrated kind of uh
uh
community and where we're going to be
starting a thing we call the
rouleological society which is an
attempt to to pull together um a lot of
uh people and activities in this area um
it's been kind of uh very interesting to
see as we've looked through you know
what happened to all those people who in
the 1980s started doing things like
following up on early work that i did in
this kind of area um you know people
have built very interesting careers
embedded in random departments of uh you
know whatever it is you know pure
mathematics computer engineering you
know
maybe physics maybe uh something else
um but they haven't really had a home
and that home i think will be part of
that home will be the field of radiology
um and uh that that's one piece i mean
another piece of new kind of science is
what i'm now calling metamodeling which
is the question of once you have a model
of something with all its detail of how
does a tree grow or whatever else
what is the essence of that model what
are the underlying primitives what are
the pure sort of computational
primitives that underlie that model
metamodeling is what kind of gives you a
to-do list for ruleology and in a sense
really ology the sort of the pure
generation of simple programs what do
they do and so on it has other analogies
another analogy is chemistry you know
chemistry particularly in the late 1800s
it's a lot of let's study this compound
let's study this compound and so on and
then later on it turns out oh we just
discovered that compound is really
useful for this particular purpose isn't
it convenient that there have been 500
papers written about it so we know so
much about this this type of compound
and that's the kind of thing that i
expect will be happening a lot with
ruleology uh in going forward
but um in terms of kind of the the
paradigms of science i mean they both
the the sort of nks paradigm of of
computational rules and their
consequences are now a new paradigm
that's come out of the physics project
of multi-computation and this kind of
multi-threaded uh observer-based view of
time and so on that seems to have a lot
to say about a bunch of fields of
science uh you know what will all these
things be called i don't know hard to
predict i i'm always curious about about
how people name things and i have to say
with a new kind of science
i i struggled for more than a decade
trying to figure out what what name
should i give this and ended up giving
it a name that in some sense
has to be an interim name in the same
sense that modern physics is an interim
name but i thought that the the since my
goal was to write a book that would be
sort of a thing at that moment in time
it wasn't intended to be a sort of a
living thing although it's uh
certainly has has stood the test of time
very well and many things have been
built on it but um the uh uh it was
intended to be sort of a moment in time
kind of thing um not uh and so that
that's why i felt it was okay to give it
a name that was in a sense a moment in
time name i mean i'm always um uh uh
struck by uh things i i noticed when i
was a kid like like in in oxford uh the
um you know they're different colleges
in oxford university and there's a
college called new college which is i
think the second oldest college it was
called new college because it was new
relative to the other one that had
already been founded sometime in the
1200s and it's it's i remember when
british currency became decimal i don't
know if it's still the case i have to
look but but um in 1970 the the coins
all said new pence five new pence and i
wondered at the time you know uh you
know how what will be the case you know
how will people view this in the future
you know it's new it's new it was from
before i was born type thing um and so
so it's funny how that how that term
evolves but i think as a representation
of sort of a moment in time it's a it's
a it's a a convenient word
uh okay lots of other questions here um
oh my a lot of interesting questions
um
okay parmese comments um about ptolemy
the ptolemy was sort of a necessary step
before copernicus and newton yes i
absolutely think so ptolemy
ptolemy did you know
a um
ptolemy did a great job he systematized
observations of astronomy that had been
you know the the longest running kind of
probably the longest running scientific
experiment ever in history was the the
babylonian astronomical diaries that
were you know every day for 800 years
uh somebody in ancient babylon made
observations of the positions of planets
and and uh also the weather and the
height of the river and the
price of corn and things but um uh
um the the um uh and they recorded them
on on stone tablets or clay tablets
um and we have maybe two percent of
those tablets they were they were
painstakingly reconstructed about 100
years ago from little shards in the
british museum and other places um there
was uh
about two percent of that 800 years
worth of um uh of daily observations and
those daily observations were were known
to hipparchus and then
200 years later to ptolemy um and that
was sort of a basis for for quite a few
of his statements about about how things
had to work
because you know if you you don't get to
observe a lot of revolutions of of uh um
well the out the furthest planet was
known at the time was saturn um uh
uranus was not discovered until
telescopes
um
right by herschel
um
and uh the um uh but but um uh it was
you know it's a long painstaking
observation of many uh astronomical
phenomena
and and of eclipses and things like that
but that was you know the the corpus
there was this big corpus um produced by
the babylonians um its hipparchus then
had a star catalog it's still a matter
of debate whether ptolemy
uh sort of uh plagiarized his his star
catalogue from hepakus
um actually my son christopher has been
studying that quite a bit and trying to
figure out you know can you actually
statistically figure out
because there are proper motions of
stars stars move around and in whatever
it was 200 years or something between
hipparchus and ptolemy some of those
stars will move a bit now obviously the
observations aren't perfectly accurate
and there are a lot of
things where you know you you point
something up and you have a kind of a
ruler type thing and you're looking at
angles from that ruler as you point it
up in the sky and it's not completely
accurate um but you know can you deduce
whether whether in fact ptolemy got his
own stark catalogue that got it from
hepakus but ptolemy you know
particularly you know the
his big thing was the almagest um
ptolemy
was uh
you know first of all had these
observations and then had essentially a
geometrical
uh you know these geometrical
constructions of how things worked and
he had essentially an explanatory theory
based on epicycles based on kind of uh
spheres rotating on spheres or circles
rotating on circles of the motion of
planets
and
the um uh there were oh gosh i don't
remember all the details of this but
there were there were an increasing
number of hacks that had to be
introduced
to account for all the planetary motion
that was observed and there's a
what is it called there's a sort of the
question of where the circles actually
where are the centers of the circles and
how does that all work and it got a bit
messy
um and uh you know then there were uh
sort of later observations i mean people
um
um
the uh but um
oh i don't know people like reggio
montanus for example that was 1400s i
guess um
was
really kind of um
uh
kind of
sort of
okay people had versions
of of ptolemy's almagest
um through
for you know
1500 years
and uh
more than a thousand years 1300 years
whatever and um there were these kind of
astronomical
uh and there were all sorts of different
kinds of um
i mean people cared about astronomy
because it was important for navigation
and so on and uh it was um
uh and there were you know there were
astro labes for for doing to sort of
computing you know you'd make a
different astrolade for a different
geographical location because it would
have things about positions of planets
and so on um and it was it was a thing
for it for a long time now you know when
copernicus came along
copernicus basically observed you can
make things a bit simpler in the
ptolemaic system by assuming that the
earth goes around the sun rather than
the other way around
it wasn't really that different at some
level um it was and computationally this
state of the art and ptolemaic epicycle
computations was actually pretty good
compared to copernicus
and it was more of a kind of a detailed
footnote not quite footnote but a
detailed point that things were a little
bit easier to understand it made more
sense you had less weird epicyclic hacks
if the earth weren't around the sun
and you know copernicus i think felt
that i mean copernicus was a um
uh gosh he um
i mean he was a kind of theologically
oriented fellow
and uh sort of thought that this idea
that maybe
maybe sort of our common sense that um
the earth isn't the center of the
universe might not be right he thought
he knew that was a shocking thing and
ended up not publishing his uh
um
they revolutionized what is it called
the i mean that's the the term
revolution comes from that copernican uh
thing where he's where his book is about
the revolution as in turning around of
the celestial spheres so to speak um but
he didn't publish that until until he
was uh
until after well it was published after
he died
um
but i think uh uh you know it is an
irony of these things that the actual
method of calculation that we use even
today for celestial mechanics for
computing ephemeris ephemerides uh
computing positions of planets and so on
is pretty much epicycles it's it's
couched in different terms it's couched
as poisson series and and these kinds of
uh essentially 480 compositions of you
know these these different terms of the
you know the piece that's associated
with the motion of jupiter and the
pieces associated with this but in the
end it's mathematically very similar to
what ptolemy did
and and so yes i think you know
unquestionably ptolemy reggie montana's
these these people were were a necessary
precursor to cap to
copernicus copernicus then
then there was uh kepler and kepler sort
of cleaned things up even further um and
uh
i think that that helped set the stage
for and kepler derived kepler's laws um
which were kind of a a
planetary motion which was something
that newton then got to explain in terms
of his inverse square law and so on that
was sort of a
newton that was kind of a
you know for for kepler it was just it
is a fact you know equal equal areas in
equal times and so on in in planetary
motion that was just a fact
for newton there was this kind of
mathematical principles of natural
philosophy there was a deductive aspect
to that you could go from something
lower level and deduce a fact like that
rather than just being sort of an
axiomatic claim
let's see
oh boy
baker asks
when newton invented calcul newton
invented two things calculus mode
several things many things
uh calculus is three laws of mechanics
the question was with our physics
project
um is it more like calculus or is it
more like inventing new laws that's an
interesting question
i think that
uh
the
the first question is what's the raw
material of the universe
what kind of a thing is it is it you
know what is the raw data structure of
the universe so to speak and that's a
big piece of this project is to
elucidate what that is
and then there's a giant formal
structure that's built on top of that
that formal structure has elements that
are very much like calculus that are
very much like how do you deal with this
form of the first thing is you have to
posit that the universe has this data
structure at the bottom but it is the
ruliad and that that's the story um and
that is something more like that is
essentially a natural law
once you have that natural law you are
then uh looking at the sort of formal
consequences of that and then you're
building up methodologies that among
other things look like generalizations
of calculus and so on and for us you
know newton got to do calculus with one
variable later on people generalize that
to calculus with several variables we
get to do calculus with fractional
numbers of variables that's just one
corner of what we need to be able to
figure out to understand how things work
um and then the whole general formal
structure of this thing we call
multi-computation that's again something
where there's a large amount of formal
structure that's sort of more analogous
to calculus the statement that
the that there is this underlying data
structure there is this underlying rule
out underneath physics and mathematics
that's a statement like kind of uh uh
you know newton's laws of mechanics the
the other thing which i suppose is a bit
like that too
is the interpretation of that you know
what is an electron in terms of that
underlying raw structure um that's
that's kind of uh
understanding that
is um uh is something more like
that that's a little bit more like uh
newton's definition of force
you know the notion of force is
something which was a thing where that
was something which was sort of plucking
out of
what happens in the world and
identifying this thing called force
later on the thing called energy and so
on
i think one of the things that's
happened in well comes out of new kind
of science and so on
is this notion of computational
irreducibility for example as a thing
that you kind of pluck out as being
important i think that's a
that's a type of thing what kind of
definition should you give
force computational irreducibility uh
branchial space these are definitions
there is a there is an underlying
reality so to speak but there are
definitions of things that we humans
consider useful to talk about for
purposes of science and so on
let's see
uh
it's a question from a diode
why was gravato electromagnetism ignored
for so long i'm not completely sure what
that refers to but
but um
you know the question of how much is
gravity like electromagnetism for
example
the laws of electromagnetism
by the time maxwell had really put them
together into maxwell's equations in the
1870s 1880s that that kind of time frame
uh you know that was pretty pretty well
established laws of electromagnetism
which had implications important
implication was there should be
electromagnetic waves you know and then
hertz
kind of was like yeah we can do an
experiment to show that electromagnetic
waves really exist people asked him
what's that good for he said well it's
kind of an interesting experiment of
course that's what gave us radio
which has been quite important
technologically um but uh
the idea that something like the
equations of electromagnetism should
apply to gravity
um that really was an outgrowth of
einstein's general theory of relativity
um the idea that electromagnetism told
you things about the world that were in
the end incompatible with mechanics with
newtonian mechanics that's what led to
special relativity the fact that in
maxwell's equations for electromagnetism
the speed of light is a constant whereas
in mechanics the way one had thought
about that uh you know a flashlight if
you're running at half the speed of
light and you have a flashlight the
light should come out at one and a half
times the speed of light which is
incompatible with kind of the way
maxwell's equations work and it was
relativity that kind of brought those
things into correspondence by saying
that well actually space and time are
distorted um and and that's why there's
no incompatibility between maxwell's
equations and the laws of mechanics but
the question of whether there would
exist things like um gravitational
magnetism
wasn't i don't think that really came up
i mean it could have done it could have
come up by by 1900 or so it could have
come up but that was the thing that was
in the end a consequence of of general
activity and it had its important
consequence was that when a photon goes
around the sun when light goes around
the sun there's a certain amount it's
deflected
bent by pure gravity
but
there's also gravitational magnetism
and because a photon is going at the
speed of light it has the effect of so
so magnetic effects are proportional to
velocity and the magnetic effect is sort
of maximal and so there's a factor of
two difference in the deflection of
light around the sun
between the newtonian theory and the
theory that includes sort of the the the
theory of gravity that is in general
utility and that that factor of two was
sort of the critical thing that was uh
was supposedly verified in the in the
1919 observation of the total solar
eclipse by eddington and friends in
south africa and so on i say it's
supposedly because it's probably that
experiment was kind of fudged um but the
result is true anyway
um
let's see
uh
well let's see
zaden comments that they disagree with
me that there's there's no end to how
infinitesimal the universe gets there's
always
more discoveries and so on
you know
those are those are inconsistent those
are those are different kinds of things
so the question of whether there is a
smallest length scale in the universe
is a completely different question for
whether there's an infinite number of
things to discover in the universe
the fact that
there may be only a countable number of
things in our universe a finite number
of things 10 to the 400 atoms of space
or something
that doesn't mean
okay so so for example time might still
go for infinitely into the future
so there's still infinite things in the
universe
and the question of whether in principle
certain things can happen in the
universe that's a formal question that's
not a question of whether the 10 to the
400 things that we happen to have in our
universe we can say given the rules that
those 10 to 400 things follow if we were
to set up this kind of configuration of
those things would we get
a you know a weird space tunnel white
hole combination thingy
um or is that just not possible given
the rules of our universe so that's a
different kind of question it's a kind
of question where you're saying does
there exist a way of taking the
underlying rules of the universe and
arranging the setup so that essentially
making a program so that it will have
this or that behavior
that's a different question and about
that there is undoubtedly an inevitably
an
infinite frontier that is there's always
more to invent there's always more to
discover because while it may be the
case that drilling down we got to the
bottom we got to the atoms of space we
got to the eams as we're calling them
the kind of atoms of existence that
underlie everything we got to those but
what consequences the operation of those
things have that is an unbounded story
and that means that
it's like saying uh if we could even if
we could ask you know is there a number
with this strange property well we can't
we might be able to prove that there
isn't such a number but if we just are
looking for that number we might be
looking and looking and looking we get
to bigger and bigger and bigger numbers
there's no end to numbers there's no end
to that the question of whether that
particular thing can can happen now we
might
be able to with a finite theory some
some deductive theory some you know
axiomatic theory of arithmetic or
whatever else we might be able to say no
no we can show that this particular
property can never occur
however large the numbers you consider
there will never be one that has this or
that property what kurt godel showed in
1931 is that with the accent with any
finite axiomatic system you can't expect
that all questions that are that are of
an arithmetic nature about like whether
certain equations will have solutions or
whatever else you can't expect there
will be a finite proof of all of those
kinds of things so in other words it
will be the case essentially durdle's
theorem and everything we know about
computation computational irreducibility
principle of computational equivalence
and so on those things basically
establish
the idea that it's an unbounded frontier
that there's always more to discover
that you'll never get to an end in
what's what's what you can imagine now
the question of what's useful to us
that's a whole different question the
question of what we choose to make
technology out of we choose to discuss
in science those are questions that are
sort of human-determined questions and
and that's uh and that's something which
where where there are different kinds of
bounds that are put on it but i think
it's a quite separate question whether
there is a smaller scale
to the universe physically and whether
there is an infinite amount of stuff to
discover in about the world now in terms
of the smaller scale thing
uh i think there's a smaller scale but
actually in our model of physics one of
the possibilities
is that the universe is always
subdivided
you know back in 1915 when einstein
wrote down his his equations for general
ultimately and the equations for for
uh gravity and the structure of
space-time
one of the consequences of those
equations is that it predicted the
universe would always expand and
einstein was like huh that can't be
right um and so he added this thing
called the cosmological term
cosmological constant which was
essentially a hack to prevent the
universe from expanding in his theory
now he later said so hubble by 1920 or
so had already discovered in the 1920s
at least had already discovered the
expansion of the universe and so
einstein his hack of adding this
cosmological term
was was a mistake
so
in kind of a possible repetition of that
mistake
it is my immediate assumption that the
universe
does not progressively subdivide itself
but it is perfectly possible that the
number of degrees of freedom the number
of atoms of space is continually
increasing
the fact that we
you know let's say that every atom of
space was was dividing into two atoms of
space would we notice
well not really not necessarily because
everything everything about us
is
relative to other things as staying the
same size but so one of the more exotic
possibilities which i have to say i
haven't explored much in the last year
and a half but one of the more exotic
possibilities is that the universe is
continually subdividing that is that the
number of atoms of space
which might have started as a very small
number it probably did in our in our
models
it can increase
but it could be the case that it is
increasing very very rapidly and
continually increasing so that when you
say
you know how many atoms of space are
there in a meter you know what is the
elementary length
you know we might have an estimate i
have a rough estimate maybe the
elementary length is uh
10 to the minus 90 meters
um
the uh um that's that's very small but
it could be the case
that at every moment in the history of
the universe the elementary length is
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and smaller smaller relative to a meter
in other words the number of elementary
lengths necessary to make up a meter
is continually increasing because the
thing that defines the elementary length
is continually subdividing so one of the
most exotic possibilities which and when
i say the most exotic possibilities
somehow often in the way that the
fundamental science works the exotic
possibility turns out to be the one
that's actually true the one that's
right at the outer limit of what we
imagine might be conceivable but you
know that possibility is the universe is
continually subdividing and so when when
when you ask me what's the what's the
length scale what's the elementary
length
i say okay let me think about that let
me go and try and measure the elementary
length let me try and look at some
complicated black hole thing that is
sensitive to the elementary length well
by the time i've made the measurement
the universe will have subdivided
so at every moment if you say i want to
make a measurement which which reveals
the fact that um
that the
um that um uh the universe is actually
made of uh you know these discrete
elementary lengths and so on uh by the
time
i can by the time an elementary enough
elementary times have gone by i can
measure that elementary length i'll be
wrong about the elementary lengths and
whenever i look to see
show me the discrete elementary length
by the time i've observed it it's
subdivided so in a sense to to my
observation the universe will look
continuous it will look as if it has no
no lower limit on size because every
time i try and measure the lower limit
on size it will kind of run away from me
and it will be have subdivided further
and so that's kind of a bizarre
possibility the bizarre edge case of is
the universe does the universe have the
smallest length scale or not as well it
does at every moment in time but the the
smallest the length scale is continually
relative to the fixed size of a meter
our experi you know our definition of a
meter it's always continually
subdividing
let's see uh
other questions here
um
okay there's a question from uh pressure
um
they say i understand a great deal of
human history was lost in ancient
alexandria
of the early mathematics are there texts
that reference concepts that are lost to
us
interesting question
um so i mean you know first thing about
alexandria the the library of alexandria
uh sort of one of the
you could think of it as an organized
university-like thing that was centered
around a library where there's a large
collection of scrolls
and i think the um um you know it's it's
often uh people
um in in being negative about different
conquerors of alexandria in egypt
people would say either that uh you know
um
uh
uh you know julius caesar was
responsible for um the the burning of
the library of alexandria or that um
uh that islamic come uh
invaders centuries later were
responsible it is true there were
various fires at the library of
alexandria and certainly skulls were
destroyed at that time i think there
were two different sites and one near
the harbor where where um uh
uh
i don't know my history very well here
maybe
56 7 bc i don't know the um uh the time
of cleopatra and julius caesar and all
that
and um i always like the um
uh the fact that cleopatra
um uh was uh
um while not having the strongest force
had the most uh you know wanted you know
the sales of our ships died purple which
was a difficult color to get because it
was from crushed beetles and so on
because it would be a you know a more
dramatic presentation at least when um
uh when the invaders showed up that's
probably an apocryphal story that that
may not be accurate but but it's it's
often
you know a lot the library of alexandria
didn't make it to modern times um in
fact you know in the end
uh there were
you know
those
most of the you know we don't have
original texts
from from antiquity for the most part
unless they're on stone inscriptions we
have typically copies of copies of
copies um and you know occasionally what
something will be discovered where
somebody used a sort of wrapping paper
um some or as a reused paper where it
was you know originally somebody had
written out a version of ptolemy or
something and then uh somebody had
written over it
some uh uh some kind of trashy novel
they weren't white novels but you know
trashy book of the um of the 1400s or
1300s or something and then it's
discovered that actually there's there's
some great text underneath and and many
texts
were thought to be lost i mean like
cicero for example i think um uh was not
was known as a historical figure but it
was not known um that uh his works had
survived um i think they were discovered
in the vatican library in the oh i don't
know
1800s maybe um if i'm remembering
correctly
and and there are lots of things in that
people reference like for example cicero
references a sort of mechanical
calculating device
um the antikythera device is the one
example that we have came from a
shipwreck of greece
um from some time between the first
century bc and first century a.d
um and that's the only example we have
from antiquity of a of a mechanical
calculating device but cicero mentions
that
um i think
who mentions that somebody uh you know a
lot of think for example troy the city
of troy
in the early ad
was thought to be sort of maybe
fictional until the 1800s when
schliemann and friends you know
discovered excavated troy um they they
made some mistakes in excavating it
because it had many layers and they kind
of blasted with uh
was it dynamite or gunpowder at that
time i'm not sure
through
through layers of of what were probably
the the homeric troy um but uh uh in any
case the you know troy was thought to be
something that didn't really exist
but turns out it did i mean the other
one is atlantis you know the lost city
of uh that sort of uh went below the
ocean type thing what was that where was
that
um you know it was a city that um was
partly described in terms of a sort of
utopian character to it um and uh but
was it a historical city where was it we
don't know a surprising number of the
things that were mentioned in these uh
uh texts in antiquity as kind of things
that were being referred to have turned
out to be real in some sense
so
you know many for example euclid um
he wrote a bunch of books that are lost
i think he wrote one on optics that's
lost and
a variety of other other kinds of things
i mean one thing that is often the case
with with um
uh you know like aristotle for example
many of his his works survive i don't
know what fractions survive but
sometimes there are pointers i mean for
example somebody like democritus i
believe none of his works survive
um and none of the
i mean the pre-socratic philosophers
very few of their works survive if any
and mostly they're known by references
often by the negative references that
were made to them in subsequent works
so a question is are there other pieces
of mathematics that was sort of known in
antiquity that really haven't been
aren't known today
you know my favorite possibility would
be that somebody did cellular automata
in you know 500 bc or something and
we'll finally find the mosaic if you
look at babylonian tablets and you look
at kinds of things they were calculating
we have lots of tablets
and they calculate lots of things we
don't really know completely whether
those were school exercises or advanced
mathematics probably they were kind of
school exercises but for example there's
a there are a bunch of geometrical
figures for example they like very much
looms uh you know kind of uh arcs of
circles pairs of arcs of circles and
questions about the area of a loon um
and they also had a thing called the um
it's translated as the cow's nose but it
has a nicer name in latin but it's a
it's a combination of four sort of a
cusp of you know these four cusps made
from circles that was a thing that
features quite big in the kind of
babylonian mathematical exercise books
um and it's something that nobody talks
about that today
um
the uh
the thing that um
uh
so in terms of kind of major areas of
mathematics that were have been lost
interesting question what might they
have been
uh you know the pythagoreans for example
had
a
a sort of a
a thinking about mathematics
that was at one level sort of modern
talking about numbers and ratios and
irrationality of the square root of two
and at some level
uh bizarrely
non-modern i mean they they thought
every number you know one through ten
had a significance you know male female
this that and the other different
numbers represented those things and
they thought it was very significant
that uh they called it the tetractis i
think one plus two plus three plus four
equals ten
okay they thought that was a very
significant fact
we don't care about that fact these days
that's not something that's sort of a
front and center fact
um they also uh they looked at numbers
like primes they think they knew about
primes they also knew about perfect
numbers um numbers which are the sum of
their divisors um except for the except
for the number itself um and uh
but perfect numbers
whereas primes have been an important
building block in many things done in
mathematics and in period numbers and so
on perfect numbers have been much less
important
i mean mercen primes are kind of a
meeting ground of perfect numbers
and uh and uh and primes but um
generally perfect numbers are just not
something one talks about very much and
for example the question oh i don't know
is are there any odd perfect numbers
that's been an open question in
mathematics from the time of pythagoras
to now
um but uh uh you know were there things
so there were things which people cared
about then
like the perfect numbers and so on which
we don't care about much today
are there things where we would say wow
that's an amazing discovery
um in mathematics
i'm skeptical
uh i think that um uh i think we've
we've picked over
the obvious mathematics probably the
most
the thing that would probably be the
most dramatic is a sort of essentially a
really logical discovery
that um
uh that that you know one could take
these rules and make this pattern now
and one thing i noticed just recently
there was a collection of babylonian
tablets that have been found that showed
different kinds of maze designs and it's
very unclear what those maze designs how
they were generated why those particular
designs are not others was there some
enumeration that was being done was it
just oh this was a doodle that was a
doodle and so on we don't know
and i mean i have to say going back to
other kinds of things even in
archaeology it's like you see these
these things i mean we're fortunate from
from ancient greece for example even
from ancient babylon that there's enough
of a continuous threat of history that
we we understand well and when there's
written language and so on we have some
context for understanding what were
these people talking about
you know when we when we see you know
the the random hand prints on the cape
paintings from you know
whatever 10 000 20 000 bc things like
that what do these mean we don't have
the slightest idea
were they just somebody you know uh sort
of trying to wipe paint off their hand
or were they some kind of important
societal thing of you know let's uh like
like a visit a book or something let's
all put our hands here to show we
visited the cable who knows what i mean
that that particular thing's probably
knowable because you can see whether
they're similar hands or not but you
know what or was it a game that was
being played who knows we don't know we
we can't project backwards from what we
know today to those things so is it
possible that there were sort of forms
of formal thinking that were done in
antiquity where we
don't uh were we don't have a connection
today to those things yes i think that's
possible i think that for example i
could imagine
uh well i think we would often call
those things art we would often say oh
there's this thing it's a geometrical
figure it's a you know it's a it's a
flint well sometimes we call it art
sometimes we might say you know this was
a yes i mean we could imagine you know
there's a there's a flint that's been
napped in this particular pattern oh it
turns out to be an incredibly clever
pattern if you're trying to uh uh you
know uh i don't know put put a uh you
know have it have it
fit in the bark of a tree when you throw
your
that thing on the end of a rope or
something like that and it's something
where we don't understand that discovery
today
um so are there possibilities that there
were things like that where people said
this was a significant thing in
mathematics
i think my my best chance for that will
be something from rheology something
from
simple rules you know you follow my like
my rule 30 seller automaton you follow
that that could have been done perfectly
well in antiquity um probably it wasn't
we don't know that for sure um
and you know had somebody excavated some
collection of stones that were in this
pattern we just said oh these are
randomly placed stones um as opposed to
wait a minute we can see there's this
rule to determine how those worked
um
okay i'm going to uh
a lot of other interesting questions
here maybe for another time
um
aaron is asking is rooliology a young
person's game an old person's game
something else what treats do you think
will be important for great
rouleologists
um
you know it's a new field new fields
aren't um
a uh
um
one of the one of the remarkable things
i've been involved in a few new fields
new areas new developments
and one of the things very interesting
about them is that people sometimes say
oh it's only the young that get involved
in new stuff it's not true
it's not true it's a distribution of
ages
and what often happens is new things
come along and those things
are a great fit for a particular person
and they just fit in with the the way
people think the kinds of things people
like to do
and you know one is lucky if the things
that are that great fit happen to be
aligned in history with when one's alive
and you know for me
i've been pretty lucky that computation
and things around the ideas of
computation you know my sort of time in
history so to speak has been well
aligned with when you know computers
started to be usable for general
purposes and and so on and so i'm i'm
pretty happy about that
but you see when when new ideas new
methodologies uh emerge
the there's usually a distribution of
ages of people who get involved because
they're people where you know they might
be in their 50s or 60s or 70s or
whatever
and um it's like wow this is a thing
that really fits with a particular way
of thinking and so on
so
what will make great radiologists
i think
it's a
uh
there's a certain clarity
ruliology is about
uh
if you
if if you are always trying to hack
things and you're always trying to say
oh i'm trying to you know i'll add this
little piece sold see what happens if i
add this thing to the rule et cetera et
cetera et cetera
um
that is not i think the best ruliology i
think the best really ology is drilling
down to the essence of things where
you're looking at the simplest rule and
the simplest this that and the other so
i think this idea of being able to sort
of drill down to the essence of things
having a kind of clarity of thought that
makes one kind of drill down to the
essence of things i think that is an
important feature of ruleology and and
being a good realiologist i think that
goes along with writing you know wolfram
language has is sort of the language of
ruleology and um uh i mean it's it's you
know we can in principle encode rules
with any for any computer for things
that aren't even computers but but in a
sense having after i've spent 40 years
doing sort of ruleology and doing
wolfram language uh it's a thing it's a
tower that's really built very ideally
for that for that purpose
and you know there's the question of is
it an elegant wolfram language program
or is it a a hacky complicated uh
program and that i think is a is an
important feature for audiology is make
an elegant program in fact a
person i know a mathematician uh just
sent me a couple of days ago a piece of
essentially really ology where he'd
written a piece of the wolverine
language program was pretty good but a
piece of it was kind of messy and so i i
pointed out it's literally one function
it's one
one thing it's just fold of this this
this
and when you see it's that you
understand what the system is doing much
better than when you see the thing as
some kind of loop and it's doing this
and that nail though um so it's kind of
that that sort of clarity of thinking
captured in this computational language
i think is an important feature of
radiology what are the simplest rules
capture them in the simplest way
represent them in the simplest way and
so on
then the next thing is
you got to be a good
uh
i would say almost unemotional
experimentalist
that is you run the programs you see
what they do
you may have a prejudice about what's
going to happen you may choose to run
particular programs because you have an
intuition about what might happen but
you have to be very kind of hands-off
and unemotional about what you think is
going to happen because you know my my
oft oft-given quote is the computational
animals are always smarter than we are
um whatever you think might happen it
will turn out that there is some way
that this little computational system
will end up being doing something
unexpected and more complicated than you
imagined and so the ability to kind of
um uh make uh to sort of do experiments
without without forcing your conclusions
on those experiments that's an important
thing and that's a that's sort of a
psychological uh turn of mind that um uh
is in different uh different fields of
human endeavor there are different
levels of value to that kind of turn of
mind i mean sometimes it's like
i believe in something and so that's
what's going to be true
independent of of of uh you know
damn the facts i'm just going to show
this is true type thing um
that's a different kind of thing than
doing this type of essentially empirical
science where you are continually
humbled by what's actually true
and where you continually realize you
didn't expect the things that actually
turn out to be true there
i think another feature
is uh
some uh is the sort of just as there's
clarity in the in the setting up rules
and so on there's also a question of
clarity in the presentation of things
and i think you know our eyes are a very
high bandwidth our highest bandwidth way
of kind of getting
stuff into our brains
and being
able to make good visual presentations
of things is a very useful asset in
theology and sometimes you know with
some things like i don't know cellular
automata
it's uh you know well i mean i guess i i
yeah i mean it's that's a that's sort of
a
you know the fact that i picked
one-dimensional cellular automata which
have a very clear visual way of being
represented and so on that was very
important for sort of the early
developments of radiological ideas and
nowadays with the physics project we're
dealing with these kind of multi-way
graphs it's rather a lot harder to get
those things into human brains they're
things that don't as naturally kind of
just like i see it i know what the
pattern means kind of thing um and so
that's that's sort of a challenge but
it's something where as you pick away at
that kind of being able to to have
creativity about those kinds of things
important
i think the um
uh
what other aspects i mean i think that
um
um
really it's this sort of clarity of
presentation i mean ruleology lends
itself
to kind of uh very
at the bedrock level
elementary explainable simple to
describe
kinds of things
more so than mathematics for example
mathematics somewhere deep inside the
system maybe something simple to
describe but one often builds big towers
on top of that the best mathematics is
ultimately quite simple to describe when
it's described in the right terms but
there's a lot of how you get there that
ends up being very ornate in ruleology
much of that ornateness is inside your
computer not
in what you have to be exposed to
i suppose another thing is
um insofar as some some part of the
story of ruleology is generating
computationally irreducible behavior
where you pretty much you have this rule
you just have to run it see what happens
but there also is the question of
picking away at it to find sort of
computationally reducible corners things
where you can actually make statements
based on traditional mathematics and so
on and there there's sort of a question
of what kind of mathematics and pretty
much it's discrete math combinatorics
those kinds of things most of the time
that's needed although with smatterings
of other areas and maybe in some of the
things we're doing now maybe category
theory higher category theory some of
these kinds of um uh more algebraically
derived mathematical ideas
may turn out to be sort of important
even at the level of radiology as a way
sort of to organize the thinking about
about these kinds of systems
but that's a that's a a really good
question i think yes the question of
what the name a ruliologist i i think
reallyologist is the right name um i
think uh a rubiographer
is probably somebody who catalogs um a
ruliologist is probably somebody who
studies a ruliographer is probably
somebody who writes down and catalogues
the rules that are out there and what
they do um and that's sort of a separate
separate thing
um
great well i think that probably uh
uh exhausts our time for for today here
um
i look forward to doing this again in a
couple of weeks
and uh actually i have
another live stream coming up in five
minutes as part of my day job
looking at uh welcome language design
um i like to also remind people
that um
uh you know i should give plugs for a
couple of things you know in case people
don't know i do write a certain amount
about sort of history of science and
technology
and uh there's a book i put out that's a
collection of things i wrote
called idea makers which is historical
biography um i haven't done when did i
last do a historical biography maybe a
year ago or so um there's a there's a
bad correlation well there's a there's a
good and a bad correlation sometimes i
do those things when there's a you know
n hundredth anniversary of some event um
sometimes i do them about people i've
known as kind of obituary pieces um but
uh
you'll find on on my
writings.stephenwolf.com you'll find um
a historical section where there's all
kinds of different things and some of
some of what i've talked about people
are asking about ptolemy and so on i i
wrote um when the eclipse total solar
eclipse that was visible visible from
the us happened a few years ago uh we
had built this website that predicted um
uh to the second when the when the
eclipse should occur in a given place
and uh that's kind of a background to
that i wrote a long historical piece
about some uh kind of um uh history of
astronomy and prediction of eclipses and
so on um but uh
uh
anyway i was um oh i was going to say
the other the thing i was going to say
was that um i think there's a form on
the web
that allows people to submit topics and
questions that they'd like me to cover
in these live streams and
please feel free to do that and i look
forward to addressing more things
another time
great well thanks very much and